welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and tenet is christopher nolan's
latest most
mind-bending film exactly the kind of
palindromic timeline puzzle to take your
mind off the fact that the people in the
cinema city 2 rose down from you are
logically the kind of people who care
the least about how their public
behavior affects others and thus more
likely to be on their phones or talking
or general mass lowering [ __ ]
yeah i'm using this snob rant to stall
because yes
spoilers ahead i will be explaining the
complex plot
and timeline of tenant in this video i
know
many of you might not have seen the film
yet some of you might not be able to
depending on where you live or maybe
you're electing to wait until it is
safer
all of that is fine this video will be
here waiting for you whenever you're
able to see the movie and then in doing
so injuring your brain
or hopefully not injuring your you know
lungs or other people you're in the
vicinity with okay here we go
tenet uses a timeline structure that i
recently categorized as
type 4 this always happened time travel
that means that all the events of the
story including the act of time travel
itself
are all fixed and predestined on a loop
they always happened the time travel is
what sets the events of the story in
motion
usually it features a character suddenly
realizing whoa this
always happened however unlike other
predestined loop time travel stories
like the terminator the time travel of
tenant is not an instantaneous
jump to the past it is time inversion
you have to continue to live and age
in real time while the world reverses
around you
until you get back to your return point
you can also just invert
objects and then invert them back in
time so that those objects continue to
exist further and further into the past
for others or for your younger self to
find bullets gold
doomsday device chunks with this in mind
let's give an overview of this story
in the future a scientist creates an
algorithm to invert
all of time but like j robert
oppenheimer who lived with guilt over
his work in the manhattan project
this scientist encoded this algorithm
into nine
physical artifacts scattering each
artifact around the world
inverting them buried in radioactive hot
spots
hoping that no one would ever go near
those spots and she took her own life to
keep this secret
but when the soviet union collapsed a
man named andre
sater took a job digging up plutonium
from a test site and he dug up
a container with gold and instructions
to amass his resources
and track down all pieces of this
algorithm seder works on behalf of
others in the distant future
who want this man in the past to compile
the algorithm artifacts and bury them
in a tunnel caved in by an underground
detonation
in the soviet secret city of stalsk12
where that algorithm would stay
buried and undisturbed for 200 years so
those future bad guys could dig it up
use that algorithm to continue that
scientist's work in the worst possible
way
inverting all of time to counteract the
effects of things like global warming
saving their future by destroying our
present in the past and stater planned
to signal these future partners that the
artifacts were in place
by simultaneously killing himself john
david washington
only ever named the protagonist in this
movie and his organization tenet
used this logic of inverted timelines to
prevent this fate from happening and tie
off all the loose ends so no one is none
the wiser so let's look at how each key
player's timeline fits into this
starting with a character whose
perspective we stay with the protagonist
he begins on a cia extraction operation
at the kiev opera house but he's saved
by a mystery man who inverts a bullet
from the floor
through a guy trying to kill him and
that mystery savior runs off with a key
chain dangling from his pack
the protagonist is then awakened and
recruited to join an organization called
tenant
and he learns that certain objects have
been inverted through time from the
future he tracks down the unique bullet
casings to mumbai where he meets
neil and learns from priya about a
russian oligarch andre
sater and then he meets michael caine in
london and briefs him about accessing
satyr through seder's wife
cat using forged goya art that she got
from an affair with a man named areppo
it's a bit complicated but sader is now
using this forged art as blackmail
keeping cat from seeing her son so they
plan to steal this art from its secure
vault at the oslo airport rotus
security by crashing a big ol plane into
it here things get
tricky see deep in the vault protagonist
and neil enter this two-sided turnstile
room and then they scuffle with this
mystery man the protagonist fights him
as the figure moves inverted in time and
blocking all the protagonists move as if
a step ahead of him and then seemingly
gets sucked out of a room by a jet
engine
no kicks meanwhile neil chases the
mystery man on the other side who moves
directionally forward he unmasks him but
then lets him go protagonists joins cat
and satyr on the amalfi coast
and he offers to steal for satyr the
ninth piece of the algorithm
plutonium-241 that he briefly had but he
lost in kiev while that artifact is
being transported in
talon but in the middle of this epic
heist an inverted version of seder uses
hostage cat to
intercept that artifact from the
protagonist they all end up in another
turnstile chamber where satyr
shoots cat and then heads off inverted
to intercept that artifact we just saw
him take
but then team tenet commando ives
explains that seder was using what's
called a temporal pincer
in which seder's team inverts themselves
from the future
to know the end result of the mission
and then invert back through that
mission
to intercept the prize the protagonist
decides to go after seder inverting all
of them
and he chases him down on the freeway
but he fails that flipping wreck that he
saw earlier was himself
and still inverted they returned to the
oslo airport protagonist uses the plane
explosion to blast himself
into the room and scuffles with his past
self then he enters the vault turn style
he runs from neal he gets an ambulance
and a future neil wheels future cat
through the vault turn style as well
then all three are now moving forward in
time in the past and are able to save
cat from her gunshot wound protagonist
meets with priya and learns of sader's
plan
so they end up forming a mission with
ives to go back to the stalsk 12
detonation where they use another
temporal pincer to stop the conjoined
algorithm from getting buried for those
future evil dudes though ives and the
protagonist in red lead the team to
fight satyr's troops and stalls 12
but then let that bomb explode so that
no one will know anything was taken
while the other team in blue with neil
have inverted themselves from the future
into this battle to extract that
algorithm before it gets buried in the
blast cave-in from the explosion
protagonists and eyes make it to the
algorithm with a bomb in the tunnel but
hit a tripwire and are trapped inside
and then there's a mysterious blue
soldier dead on the ground
we find out is inverted he has picked
the lock on the gate and he takes a
bullet for the protagonist and he has
that same mysterious keychain on his
backpack and then neil having
reverted himself to move forward in the
battle pulls protagonists and knives out
of the tunnel with the algorithm and
then the three decide to break up the
algorithm into three parts and go their
separate ways re-hide the pieces and
then you know off themselves
but then neil gives the protagonist his
third and he reveals via
the keychain on his backpack that he was
the mystery man who took the bullet for
him in the tunnel that he picked the
lock and that he was also the mystery
man who reversed the bullet in kiev and
he says that the protagonist was the man
who first recruited him that they have
known
each other for years this is the end of
a beautiful friendship neil says
paraphrasing the final line of
casablanca but that friendship is just
beginning for the protagonists who in
the future will establish the tenant
organization to close this
loop and in the epilogue protagonist
fulfills his destiny by killing off
priya
and watching as cat picks up her son max
who is hinted to be
a young version of neil which is nolan's
way of saying
this always happened and to explain how
that all makes sense we gotta look at
the timelines from the perspectives of
the other characters
seder kat neal surprisingly this movie's
holy family well before we continue we
want to thank our friends at expressvpn
for sponsoring this video do you have a
sinking feeling that you're not able to
access all the content you would like to
on the internet are you worried about
hackers or scammers stealing your info
if so expressvpn is your solution
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and can grant
you access to blocked content many
websites and services are blocked in
different parts of the world and some
countries censor websites and don't let
you surf freely like netflix in the uk
as content that us netflix doesn't have
like star trek discovery or black adder
be honest we know you've literally
watched everything on your country's
version of netflix by this point
just imagine getting a whole new batch
of content without having to pay for
a whole other streaming service
expressvpn allows you to reroute your
connection to a server in a country of
your choice
making geo restrictions a thing of the
past expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge
because i don't want anyone else to have
access to my secret google doc where i
keep track of every youtube commenter
who's ever wronged me
of us never forget expressvpn servers
operate at the fastest speeds they have
24 7 customer support and it is super
easy to use just
fire up the app and connect with one
click it is the top-rated vpn provider
rated number one by techradar cnet and
many more find out how you can get
three months free by clicking the link
in the description below expressvpn.com
new rockstars again that's expressvpn
new rockstars okay so let's look at
seder's timeline after discovering that
inverted gold 30 years ago he
established himself as a power broker in
post-soviet russia and spends three
decades tracking down all the artifacts
and building turnstiles all over the
world for him to use but his radioactive
digging left him with inoperable
pancreatic cancer and he goes insane
he's abusive to cat
and they fight on his boat in vietnam
season that forged a repo to blackmail
her and she'd never seen their son max
but then later on the amalfi coast
he meets the protagonist who saves him
from cat trying to drown during a boat
race so he lets the protagonist steal
the last artifact for him
but then of course he catches up to him
uses that temporal pincer to invert
himself back to intercept the artifact
and he continues to invert himself back
to that day in vietnam the day he
intended to kill himself and let the
world die with him
and signalling his future partners that
the algorithm was in place for them to
find in the future but of course in
stalls 12 team tenet foils those plans
and he's shot and killed by cat slid off
that deck and his body is towed away so
everyone assumes he has just disappeared
but how was
cat able to get the drop on him like
that well onto cat's timeline
so when the protagonist first contacts
cat in london she recalls the day of she
and sader's fight in vietnam
and she remembers seeing a mystery woman
dive off the boat as she was returning
to it
then later in talon seder assaults her
inverts himself
drags her into his temporal pincer to
snatch that artifact cat is left fatally
wounded by satyr's inverted bullet so
neil and the protagonist inverter with
all three rewinding back to the oslo
vault turn style where they revert back
in normal time and they heal her wound
but then they invert all the way back to
the day of the battle
and cat pretending to be a younger self
gains sader's trust on the boat
because he assumes the future version of
her is dead this is just the one he
would know from this time
but she shows him her scar and shoots
him slipping his body off the deck and
diving off
becoming the mystery diving woman that
the younger version of herself saw
now the most complicated timeline is
neil's and his brings it all together
so neil first appears the protagonist as
a rookie operative in mumbai
but he is actually much wiser than he
lets on he knows what kind of drink the
protagonist likes and when the
protagonist tries to explain time
inversion neil just kind of laughs it
off with brainy references to positrons
and entropy mentioning that he has a
masters in physics
this is because neil is actually max the
son of cat
recruited and mentored in the future by
the protagonist when he establishes the
tenant organization the two have known
each other for years
and max neal was likely to spend his
adult years studying the physics of
entropy
and it's possible that the name neil was
acquired by
max taking the last four letters of his
full name maximilian
and inverting them to become neil now at
some point in the future neil will
invert himself
to save the protagonist at the kiev
opera house he then
reverts himself moving forward normally
and makes contact with the protagonist
in mumbai he helps him find
priya then he helps him break into oslo
vault where neil chases future
protagonists and unmasks him realizing
that it's a protagonist and this all
must be part of some future inversion
then
neil joins protagonist on the talon
heist he helps rescue him alongside ives
and then
neil inverts himself with cat as they
head back to oslo
neil waits for the protagonist to go in
first and then he takes cat and himself
through that oslo turnstile with all
three of them now
moving forward just in the past but then
all three invert again
back to the day of the battle neil joins
the inverted blue team
and notices that ives and protagonists
are headed into a tripwire so he
reverts himself in the nearby turnstile
to try to warn them but he's too late
and while sniping around the tunnel he
sees another future version of himself
sniping around two
more on that in a second but then neil
pulls protagonist and knives out of the
tunnel with the artifact but he's not
done inverting folks
he hints to the protagonist that'll help
his blue team the next time around
and he leaves the protagonist with his
third of the algorithm then he heads off
to complete his final inverted loop
through the tunnel where his inverted
self will pick the lock on that gate
and takes a bullet for the protagonist
ending his life
so neil is kind of the kyle reese of the
story an agent who goes back in time to
save his future superior and save the
world
a world that extrapolating the logic of
this movie has already been saved but
only if these agents decide to go forth
with their missions that's why secrecy
is so important to tenant agents
ignorance is our ammunition as they say
things only go according to plan if
characters don't know their destinies
it's also important for inverted
travelers to avoid contact with their
past selves because if you think about
it each inversion creates three versions
of yourself existing simultaneously
version of you moving forward before you
invert it then your
inverted itself moving past you and then
that invert itself reaches another
turnstile
and then reverts so that now they're
moving forward on another layer
and neil's timeline compounds that see
during the battle of stahls
12 he was actually a child during that
period but he was also
an inverted agent saving the protagonist
in kiev and then he was a
reverted agent chilling until mumbai
moving on to oslo and talon
and then in talon he inverts again back
to oslo
and then that same kneel reverts forward
but then shortly after
inverts again to stalk he reverted to
move forward mid-battle
and then inverted once more to pick the
lock and save the protagonist that is at
least six
nils existing at the same time maybe
even more and along with the palindromic
structure you might have noticed some
key words scattered throughout this film
the villain named satyr the opening
scene at the opera
the oslo security company wrote us cats
forger a repo
and with tenet all these words come
together to form the famous latin satyr
square
a four-dimensional palindromic matrix
found in the ruins of pompeii
and across europe with an unknown origin
of meaning max was said in this movie to
be visiting pompeii
perhaps nolan is suggesting that the
seder square from history was a relic
from the future
inverted back through time to start to
give young max slash neil an idea of his
future role in the fate of mankind
look folks there's obviously so much to
this movie so many visual details so
many layers of meaning i'm eager to
unpack it all but it may
take me a bit of time meantime if you
have any further questions about the
film the best way to find me is on new
rockstar's official discord server which
we offer to patrons of new rockstars of
any tier even a dollar a month just go
to patreon.comrockstars subscribe to new
rockstars and hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
me rockstars and thank you for watching
and uh to those three a-holes in san
diego amc who couldn't stay off your
damn phones the only reason i didn't get
up to yell at you is i
am you from the future inverted trying
to make sense lieutenant by watching it
backwards
this is what you have to look forward to
have fun with that
[Music]
you